al menos una vez a la semana deborah
snyder coronel retirada y piloto de
helicóptero uso durante 22 años para
eeuu se reúne con las compañeras
militares para diseñar soluciones de
vivienda a mujeres y familias de
veteranos a menudo estas conversaciones
se desvían para abordar sus historias de
agresión sexual militar
yo personalmente le puedo decir que
cuando estaba sirviendo en korea el
comandante de mi compañía tenía a todas
las mujeres en una habitación éramos
sólo mujeres y nos preguntó cuántas de
nosotras habíamos sido acusadas o
abusadas sexualmente y todos levantamos
la mano
en el ejército lo que yo he visto es que
en la mayoría de los casos yo diría que
más de un 80 por ciento ha sido acosado
sexualmente y mucho queda sin reportarse
porque hay muchas repercusiones
yo seguiría en la fuerza pública si eso
no hubiera pasado pero como lo reporte
entonces las oportunidades de cerrarla
me mandaron a hawai éramos las mujeres y
nos repetimos que solo las más fuertes
sobreviviría para wii nos aseguramos de
proteger nuestras espaldas porque
sabíamos que los hombres venían por
nosotras
lo que me molesta son las mujeres que
han sido abusadas
yo creo que ellas nunca los operan de
hecho le estoy ayudando a una en este
momento y ella está yendo a terapia y
sirvió al país hace 30 años y todavía
pasa tiempos difíciles
le garantizo que si nosotros siguiéramos
en la fuerza pública no le estuviéramos
hablando en este momento
débora es hoy directora de su fundación
y vive en virginia a unos 30 minutos de
washington con su familia ya grabó el
acogió pruebas de su abuso y su superior
fue retirado del cargo pero como
retaliación perdió oportunidades de
educación militar este
significa
uno de los acosos más significativos que
sufrí fue cuando me en comandante trato
de besarme y básicamente me empujó hacia
él cuando le estaba haciendo un resumen
de una carrera de 5 kilómetros que
planeábamos en el batallón
según el departamento de asuntos para
veteranos
55 por ciento de las mujeres han
experimentado acoso sexual militar para
muchos el problema viene desde arriba
así lo dice key king & trick que también
fue acusada sexualmente hoy es encargada
de las relaciones de gobierno para la
organización veteranos de irak y
afganistán por américa
fernando hay definitivamente situaciones
de agresión y acoso sexual de altos
rangos a mujeres en rangos bajos no es
reportado con frecuencia por el riesgo
que esto puede tener para la carrera
militar y normalmente lo que vemos son
reportes de casos que pasan en rangos
bajos en cuanto a la sistematicidad
muchas veces hay una falta de tolerancia
cero' y dejar que alguien se quede como
miembro del servicio militar cuando ha
cometido un crimen atroz argumentando
que es bueno para la misión
el 16 5% de los militares en eeuu son
mujeres y muchos de los servicios que
ofrecen los centros de salud para
veteranos se enfocan en los hombres
además muchas mujeres que buscan ayuda
en estos centros corren el riesgo de
revictimización
de
estabilizar start-up la forma como
algunos de nuestros centros para
veteranos están establecidos esto puede
terminar siendo un estilo de pasarela
con gente que está en la entrada
entonces las mujeres tienen que pasar al
frente de todos estos hombres y esto
puede desencadenar en nuevos acosos
porque los que están en la entrada
pueden decir cosas ofensivas o hacer
algo que lleve a involucrar las
autoridades
el pentágono ya empezó a tomar acciones
lloyd austin secretario de defensa se
comprometió a trabajar con el congreso
para cambiar el código militar de
justicia y que ahora sea un órgano
independiente el que procese los casos
de agresión sexual y no la cadena de
mando militar entre otras reformas
ya siempre quise decirle un día a mi
hija que debería servirle al ejército
porque yo me inclino por el ejército
pero me hubiera alegrado que fuera parte
de cualquier rama militar sin embargo
con las condiciones actuales si no hay
cambios probablemente le rogaría que no
se alisten para asegurar el apoyo de su
esposo fue clave para salir adelante y
cree que los hombres juegan un rol muy
importante escuchando las y asistiendo
las
mi consejo a las mujeres militares es
que siempre hagan lo mejor y que siempre
tengan a un amigo a su lado para que
sean menos propensas a los abusos
sexuales
la herida abierta que deja el abuso
sexual militar a las mujeres que
pusieron en riesgo sus vidas para
servirle a eeuu en guerras interminables
y los retos que afrontan como veteranas
hacen que muchas se pregunten valió la
pena